Unreal Engine 5's Fracture mode is actually part of the Chaos Destruction toolset, and
this allows you to create cinematic quality fractures that run with real-time performance.
The Fracture Editor allows you to create fractured versions of any static mesh that can be used
to help increase the realism of destruction no matter how that destruction is caused.
Within the Fracture Editor, you have full control over how something should look when
it fractures, and you can even add multiple levels of destruction, allowing you further
control over how something looks when it starts to be fractured during the middle of its fracture
and its final, end-destructed state.
Let's pop over to the Editor now and take a look at this tool in a little more in-depth.
Now first, before I start, I do need to get something to do Fracture, so I'm going to
come up here to my shapes and add a sphere.
There we go.
Then what I'm going to do is I'm going to come up here to my selection mode and go to Fracture.
Now with the Fracture tool open, the first thing I need to do is create a geometry collection.
I'm going to do that right there.
I'm going to go ahead and just leave this all default and just press the Create Geometry
Collection.
There we go.
Now once that has taken place, the next thing that I need to do is come down to the actual
Fracture, and you can see there's multiple options here.
For this demo, though, we're just going to click on Uniform, and then as soon as I do
that, I want to hit the Fracture button right there.
That's going to actually fracture stuff.
Now I can explode things out to see how my fracture takes place.
One of the other things I'm going to do here is I'm going to take this Break Damage Propagation
and set that up to like five so that we can see what happens when I press Play here.
We should be getting some.
Might need to just bring this up a little bit higher in the level.
Let's just do that one more time.
There we go.
That's what we wanted to see.
That's the first thing, Break Apart.
So again, just needed to bring it up a little bit higher, but that is the Fracture tool.
Again, it's very simplistic to use, but it can give you really finite control over how
your fractured objects are going to look, increasing the realism no matter what your
end target happens to be.